[Musique]
mulhouse centre médico-social fonderie
pour cette toute jeune fille aujourd'hui
ces rendez vous avec sa purée culte rice
croissance bois motricité la matinée est
consacrée à un bilan
les puéricultrices de la protection
maternelle et infantile suivent
développement des enfants mais conseille
surtout les parents c'est pour apporter
une aide une orientation par an et puis
pour que pour l'enfant il évolue bien
dans un milieu adapté le rôle parental
il est très compliqué et du coup c'est
parfois on ne peut être un peu perdu et
on a besoin d'être aiguillé surtout sur
ces choses-là ya différentes
possibilités du coût des dents groupe ou
plutôt individuelle et c'est en fonction
de chacun ce qu'il a envie de de la
manière dont son envie d'aborder les
choses la création de la protection
maternelle et infantile remonte à 1945
depuis 1986 cette mission est géré par
les départements et s'intègre dans leur
politique santé l'objectif n'a pas
changé depuis 75 ans la prévention en
termes de prévention santé on est on
agit depuis de très longues années pour
avant la naissance on se surveille le
coup suit les grossesses grâce à la
protection maternelle infantile qui sont
les services du département
on suit ensuite à la naissance ensuite
l'enfant qui est qui est suivi par nos
puéricultrice 130 professionnels
interviennent à la protection maternelle
et infantile dans le haut-rhin des
médecins des sages-femmes des
puéricultrices des psychologues des
éducatrices jeunes aux enfants des
assistantes sociales et du personnel
administratif
le service assure de très nombreuses
missions pendant et après la grossesse
mais aussi en matière d'accès à la
contraception
si on peut trouver les équipes de la pmi
dans les centres médico sociaux sur
l'ensemble du territoire
le gros de leurs missions s'effectuent
hors les murs il ya plein d'autres
actions qui sont menées horse
ces centres quelles sont les actions qui
sont menées aux domiciles des parents au
domicile des parents parce que on a
besoin de les aider dans leur
environnement
on va avoir aussi des articles
l'assurons avec les maternités les
puéricultrices les sages femmes voilées
régulièrement dans les maternités un
autre version de notre activité c'est la
planification familiale
donc on a un travail d'information
un travail de consultation et un travail
d'accompagnement des femmes ont le même
ou dans nos centres ou en partenariat
avec les services de gynécologie 10 à 20
% des mamans et des bébés haut rhinois
sont suivis à un moment par la pmi si le
service cible en priorité des personnes
pouvant avoir des difficultés d'accès
aux soins
tous les parents sans exception peuvent
demander conseil toutes les mamans qui
sortent de maternité elles peuvent avoir
besoin d'avoir un conseil un soutien ça
peut être un soutien ponctuel ça peut
être un début d'un accompagnement plus
long
au cours des années de l'enfant puisque
notre service a en charge les enfants de
0 à 6 ans pour ce jeune couple ce matin
ces rendez vous de suivi de grossesse
la prise en charge de la pmi peut en
effet commencé bien avant la naissance
ici les médecins réalise le même suivi
et les mêmes actes médicaux qu'à
l'hôpital ou en libéral l'atout de la
structure départementale son réseau de
professionnels et tendu les patientes
peuvent ainsi être aisément aiguiller
vers l'ensemble des autres acteurs temps
des champs médicaux que sociaux pendant
un suivi de grossesse on essaye de
prendre soin de la femme mais surtout on
fait un suivi médical tout à fait normal
qu'on fait ici entre les médecins de pmi
les sages-femmes de pmi est en lien
étroit avec les médecins hospitaliers
qui sont nos spécialistes bien
évidemment compte nous on sait plus
donner toutes les réponses adéquates
pour avoir un bon niveau de suivi de
grossesse les femmes viennent ici en
consultation on les examine ont fait les
échographies ont prescrit les bilans il
ya certes un bilan qui peuvent être pris
en charge tous les bilans obligatoire
par le conseil général
donc on peut vraiment offrir un suivi de
grossesse entre médecins sages femmes
avec aussi des collègues conseillère
avec tout un réseau intra conseil
général avec les psychologues par
exemple mais aussi extra conseil général
avec les hôpitaux avec les services de
prise en charge des addictions des
choses comme ça juste des exemples toute
femme enceinte peut demander à
rencontrer une sage femme lors de sa
grossesse
aujourd'hui cette jeune femme a rendez
vous pour un bilan médical mais
l'essentiel de l'activité des
sages-femmes territoriale de la pmi
consistant du conseil aux futures mamans
pour cela elle se déplace sur l'ensemble
du territoire même si on pense qu'une
grossesse voilà c'est tout à fait normal
il suffit d'un suivi médical c'est vrai
que la plupart des mamans ignorent
qu'elles peuvent rencontrer une
sage-femme et celles qui ont eu
l'occasion de rencontrer une sage femme
se rendre compte que on peut échanger
différemment avec une sage-femme que ce
qu'on fait lors d'une consultation
médicale
en fait les préoccupations des mamans
sont les mêmes quand une femme est
enceinte elle pose et se pose plein de
questions autour de ce bébé qui va venir
il est des fois elles n'osent pas aussi
poser des questions donc je pense que le
fait de rencontrer une sage femme pour
toute maman qu'on ait des difficultés de
langue ou sociale ou pas je suis
convaincu c'est un plus pour toutes les
mamans d'avoir ce ton des changes avec
une sage-femme qui peut aborder la
question de la grossesse
autrement que sur le champ médical donc
vous avez une tête on va démarrer
laon premier comprimé et la prendre
autre volet important de l'activité de
la protection maternelle et infantile la
planification familiale la structure
départementale en assurent les deux
aspects l'information et la prescription
s'ils le souhaitent les jeunes mineurs
qui rencontre les médecins peuvent
rester anonyme dans l'histoire au départ
c'étaient les centres de planification
qui était agréé pour recevoir les jeunes
pour pouvoir voir une contraception sur
l'accord des parents maintenant les
choses ont changé je dire à tout médecin
peut prescrire une contraception donc
effectivement les gènes avant la
possibilité d'aller maintenant un petit
peu partout mais on intervient dans les
établissements scolaires on essaie de
voir une tranche d'âge pour les
sensibiliser et surtout pour pouvoir
échanger avec eux sur sur vraiment les
questions d'amour et à ce moment là
celle que ceux qui souhaitent peuvent
venir que ce qu'on soit garçon qu'on sa
fille peuvent venir ici dans un centre
de planification pour assurer
l'information du jeune public
les équipes de la pmi se déplace dans
les établissements scolaires du
département
l'objectif de ces rencontres n'est pas
de faire la morale aux adolescents mais
de les aider à maîtriser tous les enjeux
propres à l'utilisation ou non de la
contraception car un ado informé en vaut
deux
train